hey folks I'm Kurt Davina and today
we're talking about Elder Scrolls
Online's new expansion gray more and
joining me is the creative director rich
Lambert rich pleasure to have you
glad you're here how you doing good man
good - thanks for having me absolutely
so I just want to first jump into that
all the scrolls online has consistently
been expanding and adding places over
what is it since 2014 now
congratulations on that this ever
explained universe six year we've we've
had the opportunity to see areas of
Tamriel new and both old expanded in
different ways
when it came to gray more what was it
the decision specifically to return to
Skyrim this time around and what was
that process in taking it back in time
on the western side of things a lot of
what we do when we're thinking about the
next chapter and where we're gonna go
next is kind of looking in the past and
what we've done before and so when you
look at what we did with elsewhere it
was you know kind of desert and the
Khajiit aren't silly but it was a little
bit more happy-go-lucky they're a
different culture and so we wanted to
make sure that we told a story that felt
very different and go to a different
location and we couldn't think of
anything more kind of opposite than
elsewhere then going to Skyrim and
exploring the north and the sands to the
winter yeah now already all the scrolls
and correct me if I'm wrong Tamriel
unlimited specific you know it's mostly
takes place in the second era and I
think Skyrim takes place in the third
like the end of the third era is that
correct boy so Skyrim I think it's
actually the fourth era over a thousand
years ahead of where we are in in eso
its timeline it gives us a lot of
opportunities to really explore things
that you know we probably couldn't
necessarily explore in the in the fourth
era when when it came to that those
decisions like Skyrim is near and dear
to I think a lot of us in the media
especially so what were some of the
challenges you faced when adapting
lesser in Skyrim again
especially in you know a thousand years
in the past I think the big thing is
just player expectation you know when
you say hey we're going to western sky
run people instantly know oh solitude oh
I'm going here I'm gonna explore this
kind of stuff and so trying to manage
that and balance that kind of whole how
much nostalgia how much familiarity do
we put in versus new stuff and I think
with gray Moore we've really found that
balance where the Overland area is being
able to go and explore Skyrim and going
into solitude and seeing dragon bridge
those kind of things are very very
familiar to players that kind of feel
like home and where we really forged our
own path and kind of went our own way
was when you went down into black reach
and that's where we got to show you
things that you've never been never seen
before in in Skyrim was it difficult for
you like it when it came to making those
decisions and and trying to hone in and
keep something like solitude a certain
way that is familiar to players but then
also like was there any like push and
pull for the creative side of wanting to
do something different wanting to change
it in any way sure I mean we always kind
of want to go off and do our own things
and tell our own stories I mean you
can't really top Skyrim right like
that's pretty much the masterpiece right
there so how do we do our own things and
fortunately we've been doing this for a
while we've gone to a few really iconic
locations over the years and so we've
been able to kind of figure out a good
process for that thankfully Skyrim has
some dark moody you know history and of
itself what point was it was always
something you wanted to do when
returning and like leaning really
heavily into vampirism as like Dawnguard
and all those things are so heavily
ingrained was it always something you
knew you wanted to do from the start
yeah I mean that kind of goes back to
the how do we tell a completely opposite
story than what we just did and a lot of
times what we do you know Matt and I
Matt is the the game director Matt fire
our when we're coming up with kind of
ideas and it's all kind of concepts for
the next chapter the next area a lot of
times we just throw one word back and
forth at each other just to kind of
establish mood and feel so
with Mauro and it was nostalgia was the
word and with summer said it was high
fantasy that was that that was the word
that kind of carried it through and and
could really help the team's really
grasp what the story was that we're
trying to tell with elsewhere it was
revenge
you know dragons and the revenge and so
it was a revenge based story and with
grimoire it was gothic like that was
that was the thing we wanted to tell
this dark gothic story because that was
the the antithesis of you know the
keshite and kind of the light-hearted
story even though it was about revenge
it kind of came across as a little bit
more lighthearted and kind of going from
elsewhere into gray more what has it
been like you've been with the game
since 2007 you said earlier correct what
has it been like to see this game evolve
over time through ups and downs and then
into kind of like finding what I think
the best identity that the game has
currently what was that like well I will
say it was trying early on you know we
didn't have the the best of launches
with with PC you know but really it's
I'm super proud of what we've been able
to do and super proud of the team you
know we didn't give up we knew we had a
good core game and so kind of going
through and trying to really figure out
what the essence of Elder Scrolls was
you know I actually worked on Oblivion
that was the first game that I worked on
when I when I joined Bethesda you know
being able to kind of see the game you
know Elder Scrolls online go from not
quite knowing what it is you know is it
an MMO is it an RPG to kind of knowing
and absolutely understanding what it is
and what makes Elder Scrolls of Elder
Scrolls game has been super fulfilling
and I think the players you know have
definitely noticed that and definitely
commented on that over the years as well
is you know the game feels like an Elder
Scrolls game which is just amazing
praised for us on the net at sauce I
don't have the time for any memos
anymore than the way the way I used to
and I feel like Elder Scrolls online
kind of created that happy balance of
feeling as though I'm surrounded on
other people feeling that I'm involved
with things that are happening that
people are on their own quests around me
but still following along and what feels
traditional elder scrolls storyline or
questline in some ways and so it like
just oh it's just it's good work what
I'm saying as a player that I think
that's great yeah it's cool to be able
to play an MMO solo if you want to or
you can play with friends right like
it's nice having that freedom so going
forward you know you've been with us for
so so long you've seen in so many
different ways
is there any what is how do you envision
ESO growing and expanding in the future
now I know that's a broad question and
things you may not be able to talk about
but what like in in your own fantasy
world that kind of what do you want to
see with ESO happen I think you can kind
of tell what we're working towards if
you kind of follow the updates and how
we've been working through so we're
slowly filling the map of Tamriel out we
still have a number of places that we go
and explore but there's also the plains
of oblivion you know there it's this
huge huge massive world so once we do
get to that point of kind of filling up
Tamriel there's there's no shortage of
places we can go and can't explore but I
think the the big thing is is we're not
gonna slow down like people love the
update kids that we have you know it's
hard on the team you know we do
quarterly updates I don't really think
anybody does that the way we do in the
business and we have been doing it for
five years now grammar was our 26th
update to the game in almost six years
so that's a lot over the course and it's
definitely one of the reasons why I
think yes I was where it is today is
because we're constantly updating the
game and players always have something
new to come back to and going and
speaking of the players how much of the
community do you feel the players shift
that really kind of guys what is your
creative vision especially as the
creative director of the game they're a
big part of what we do you know we get
obviously lots of slash feedback you
know there's an in-game tool that
players can can type in feedback
requests and things into into the game
social media is a big thing twitch you
know I'm in twitch streams all the time
just kind of watching what players are
doing listening to kind of what they're
doing and it has
a big impact on kind of what we do and
where we kind of set our sights next one
thing I personally appreciate about
Elder Scrolls online is that regardless
of where you come into the game it is
quite approachable in the sense that
it's its it feels like it's design in a
way that I can play solo and that I can
play with a group of people and you have
these very specific quest lines that
that evolve on their own and tell
specific story in this case great more
ads vampirism and and antiquities and
all of these not kind of all they're
additional things how did you continue
to make gray more approachable say if
this was the first time I would be
getting into Elder Scrolls online I
think the big thing with that is just
kind of the way the game is structured
like you mentioned it's approachable you
know we don't have arbitrary level gates
that prevent you from going and
exploring the world you can go anywhere
you can play with anybody you don't have
to spend two years leveling up through
all the older content in order to come
to the new stuff you can just jump in
and play right away so that rate there
is instantly approachable and then I
think the other thing that we do
extremely well with grey morin and all
our chapters really is NPCs in the world
recognize your exploits and so if you've
done things with them in the past they
have a different set of greetings and
will be an act slightly different than
if you've never been there before so it
reinforces to the player you know that
all of the stuff they've done over the
years you know matters and and really
that helps make the world feel more
believable and more alive you know and
then when it comes to you mentioned
antiquities I think this is a thing that
we've never done before and this is kind
of a it's not questing it's not killing
it's kind of a new way to play the game
and players who aren't necessarily
familiar with mmo's or familiar with
RPGs you know it gives them that kind of
familiar you know mini game style of
gameplay that they kind of get in and
dig into and understand and learn more
about what the lore in the world is
which
helps them overall on their journey
through the world and something you said
about NPCs acknowledging and remembering
things that you did this one you can
become a vampire and it's a it's a big
soul focus of the those decisions you
make and almost be in the in the essence
of being a vampire you're gonna have to
make decisions
speaking of vampire what was that like
giving a player the ability to kind of
put themselves in a line of danger with
NPCs with guards and stuff like that
that maybe wasn't as otherwise liked as
much of a focal point in previous
expansions vampires we've had the
vampire skill line in the game for while
really since launch but it wasn't a full
experience it was really ultimately a
couple of passive abilities and maybe an
active ability that you would use but
for the most part it was this passive
thing you did it you just got more power
when we started working on Graeme or
when we really figured out what the
story was and how it was gonna be
centrally focused on this vampire
storyline we wanted to take the time to
update vampires for players that they
could feel like they were a vampire and
part of that was yes integrating that
into the justice system so if you do
vampiric things near NPCs in the world
they will react and they will react very
strongly and not like that but also just
how you feed how you gain power now you
have to actually participate in the
skill line and participate in feeding to
gain more power and that really turns it
into this full experience and makes it
so that the players yet do feel like
they're part of the world but also feel
like they are being a vampire which is
just cool so the last thing we've
touched a lot about antiquities and
vampirism and kind of these different
new elements or develop elements but
what is it like the key thing that you
really think makes gray more different
from the previous expansions that would
provoke players go and explore gray more
well that's its Skyrim so you know you
can go in and explore this familiar
place but it's slightly different you
know it's a thousand years in the past
but it is also our darkest story that
we've told it's very different than kind
of the themes that we've taught
down in the past and so if you want that
to kind of little bit of nostalgia of
you know exploring and learning more
about the the world that you're so
familiar with in the area you're so
familiar with it's the perfect
opportunity to jump in and start playing
all right that's all the time we have
today rich thank you so much for being
here
while you're here for this moment see
your thing do you do the thing you got
to do tell us what this very more
available can we play it now agree mores
available pretty much on everything so
we just launched on stadia yesterday
it's on console it's on PC Mac so yeah
we it's out there it's full out there
pretty much anymore anything you want to
play on you can go and play it on now
well thank you so much for your time
rich truly once more I'm Curtin Davina
this is GameSpot and for any other Elder
Scrolls online or gray more news make
sure to come back here to check it out
alright till next time see you later
you